on november 4th 2008 the people of
california voted to fund this
a high-speed rail line
many countries around the world have had
high-speed trains for decades and this
would be the us's attempt to finally
catch up
the train would whisk passengers from la
to san francisco in under three hours
and it was all set to open in 2020.
today it's 2022 and california's
high-speed rail project is famous
for being a disaster will be the most
expensive project in state history a
train that's going to nowhere running to
nowhere all that's there today is this
one section still under construction
from bakersfield to merced
but the failure of this rail line isn't
just california's problem
it's an ominous sign for big projects
all over the u.s
we see other advanced economies all
around the world that are able to do
this so they can do it so why can't we
in other words what is it about the u.s
that made california's high-speed rail
line so hard to build
just to be clear this was a pretty good
idea
a lot of people travel between san
francisco and la but the trip takes at
least six hours by car
it's less than an hour by plane but
that's not counting time in two of the
country's busiest airports
so a two-hour and 40-minute trip by
high-speed rail made sense california
just needed to design a route that
connected its big cities efficiently
it's really about population density and
how quickly you can serve
areas of high population density this is
ethan elkind director for the climate
program at uc berkeley law school and
host of the local state of the bay radio
show you really want those centers where
there's a lot of people working and
living within a few kilometer range of
the station if you don't have that then
it's not worth a high-speed rail stop
but that's easier said than done
in the early 2000s the california
high-speed rail authority considered two
routes in southern california this one
went straight up the i-5 highway while
this one looped eastward and stopped in
palmdale
it was 34 miles longer and studies
estimated it would be 12 minutes slower
yet ultimately this was the route they
chose
so what happened so the palmdale stop
was really added at the behest of the
los angeles county board of supervisors
that wanted to see a stop for high-speed
rail in palmdale if you have the county
uh that the high-speed rail line is
going through opposing it that can
create real political problems can
create litigation problems can create
permitting problems
palmdale politicians understandably
wanted the trains riders and business
opportunities to come to their district
the problem was that they had the power
to hold up the entire project to do so
they have this power because the us
government gives it to them
the u.s is a federal system meaning
power is divided between the federal
government and state governments which
in turn grant some power to local
governments when it comes to
infrastructure a lot of the power and
responsibility is often on this local
level that's the compromise that we make
here in the united states we believe in
local control to some extent
you know representative democracy the
downside of that is you're trying to get
a project at this scale built you know
it does take a lot of compromise and in
order to build a 1300 kilometer
high-speed rail line the state
high-speed rail authority had to
compromise with a lot of local
governments in the bay area politicians
pushed for this route instead of this
one even though it was much more
expensive and slower for travelers
coming from san francisco
and in the central valley the route
stops in all these cities instead of
going up this faster route in order to
ensure support from the politicians here
all of these little compromises began
adding up making the routes slower and
more expensive which was a problem
because the funding was already on shaky
ground
when california voted in 2008 the state
estimated it would need 33 billion
dollars to complete by 2020
but voters were told that california
taxpayers would only have to pay 9
billion
that's because the planners were
counting on the federal government to
chip in 12 to 16 billion dollars and it
made some sense the federal government
spends tens of billions of dollars a
year on transportation infrastructure
the problem was only a fraction of it
goes to trains
partly because unlike most countries
with high-speed rail the us has a stark
political divide on whether we even need
it
by 2010 the democrat-controlled congress
had allocated just over three billion
dollars for the project
not nothing but not nearly as much as
the state wanted
but by 2015 the democrats had lost
control of congress to the republicans
who opposed this kind of mass transit
project
more money for california's speed rail i
call it high cost rail is a terrible
idea none of these funds can be used for
high-speed rail they made it very
difficult for any further federal money
to reach this project leaving it well
short of funding
it's an example of how in the u.s
long-term projects can be at the mercy
of whichever party is in power
since they often have the power to stall
it at any time
and it's not just the federal government
private citizens can also hold things up
it took less than a year for people to
start suing the california high speed
rail project
many cases were based on a law called
the california environmental equality
act known as sequa
sql requires the government to study the
environmental effects of any government
project explore alternatives and release
the findings in a report it's very easy
to find a hole in that assessment and
then file a lawsuit essentially target
practice for lawyers many of these
lawsuits had legitimate concerns some
farmers in the central valley worried
about the train damaging their
agricultural land irrigation systems and
crops but others simply use sequo to try
and keep the project from being built in
their neighborhood
this is a common way in the u.s for
private citizens to block important
projects like housing or infrastructure
it's not cheap to bring a sql lawsuit
sometimes you've got very powerful
homeowners groups that have sued and
forced changes or at least delayed the
project and run up costs for the high
speed rail line these lawsuits were like
roadblocks and in order to clear them
the state had to hire legions of
expensive lawyers which added time and
costs i think you do want to have a
participatory system you do want to have
people able to
say their piece and you want policy
makers to respond just that you don't
want to get to the point where a hyper
local interest has veto over a project
really statewide importance
but take away local politicians and
federal drama and lawsuits and this
project still would have faced problems
the state body in charge of designing
and managing this project was the
california high-speed rail authority
there was just one problem
the high-speed rail authority had never
built anything like this
whoops obviously it's a tried and true
technology globally but it was new in
north america when california tried it
certainly we didn't have the confidence
in-house how to build it here
when japan and france were building
their high-speed rail networks they had
legions of experienced engineers inside
their governments
but the california high-speed rail
authority had to hire consultants and
contractors to handle the design and
construction
these consultants were four times the
cost in some cases of what it would have
cost to hire someone just to do it
in-house another reason why the
authority had to keep increasing the
estimated cost of the project which
today is up to 113 billion dollars to
complete the whole line but the state
only has enough money to build this
section in the rural central valley
even if it can get the rest it would
probably take a few more decades to
finish this project
the high-speed rail is a cautionary tale
for really big transformative projects
in the us we need all sorts of rail
transit bus lanes new renewable energy
facilities all the things we need to do
to to have a more sustainable and
vibrant economy but the us is falling
further and further behind its peers
because the political compromises
underfunding lawsuits and extra costs
that hampered california's high-speed
rail can also happen to any other big
project the u.s takes on
[Music]
you